歡迎收聽古埃,我是羨慕公,本集節目由MagEasy贊助
很多人換新手機,第一個買的就是透明殼
剛剛裝上去看起來很漂亮
但最常遇到的問題,用一陣子開始發黃
最後只能夠任賠換殼
透明殼除了好看,更重要的是能不能夠長期持有
MagEasy的Bright360M透明抗黃磁吸支架手機殼
經過UV照射192小時後不發黃
可以保留心機用的顏色跟透明感
不需要一直短線進出更換手機殼
還有10年不發黃保固
透明殼不用擔心變色,用起來更安心
360度旋转支架可以依照观看需求调整不同倾斜角度
平常追剧看盘或是工作都可以直接使用
Bright360M的支架搭配新机不同颜色设计
呈现原机原色加上金属按键整体质感大提升
平常如果你容易摔手机或是需要更高规格防护
可以选择Odyssey Ultra M
终极防摔磁吸支架挂绳手机壳
最高可以达到25英尺高规格防摔
同样有360度旋转支架搭配25ml Fitlock Utility Strap
机能快拆挂绳
手机可以直接挂在身上
需要使用时一秒快速拆卸
日常移动更方便
也可以减少手机裸体的风险
搭配Lens 蓝宝石镜头贴
把镜头的刮伤和碰撞风险一起顾好
与其一直换壳一直任陪布
一开始就把手机的防摔抗黄支架
跟镜头防护配置完整
现在点击我们资讯来连接
前往MagEasy的官网
输入国外专属的优惠码GOOAYE
首字母要记得大写
立即享有订单92折优惠
好那开头要先跟大家推一个超棒的东西
就是白色可樂
不好意思
可是以前我都一直覺得
白色可樂是不入流的可樂
你跟我講你喝白色可樂
對不起我們可能沒有辦法當朋友
雖然聽起來像是玩笑話
或者有些人覺得說幹嘛這樣
不是因為白色可樂不是人喝的東西
我如果去你家
那我們今天吃披薩
你也把白色可樂拿出來
對不起我要去Seven去買我自己的飲料
你這個飲料我是無法接受的
可是最近白色可樂
他們出了一個叫生可樂的東西
太厲害了
我覺得真的太厲害
而且它一樣是零卡
這個東西是一定要推廣的
就只要有好的產品
我們一定都會推廣給大家
我們不是那種盲信者
甚至如果它這個東西
後來越做越好
我也不排除
我就會變成百事可樂的一個信奉者
可是好的東西就是一定要讓大家知道
這個生可樂
我覺得要去買來喝看看
雖然這跟我們節目的話
一點關係都沒有
但我就是開頭想要跟大家推薦一下這個
然後昨天去跟幾個
資深美少男美少女吃飯的時候
然後他們在聊自行車
我就發現說
其實自行車就是
中年人的戰鬥陀螺
差不多是這樣的一個意思小時候你可能拜託你把他媽去買一個幾百塊的陀螺給你然後等到你變成中年人你有經濟自主權之後他們就是花幾萬幾十萬去升級裝備
求了什麼就讓我童年
單純可以被量化的快樂
還有怎麼樣
還可以把人家幹倒那樣的一個感受
我就看到三個自行車狂熱者
在那邊互相打擂嘴炮
其中一位
我跟你講我對自行車是完全不熟悉
會騎腳踏車
只是我不知道裡面設備是怎樣
可是我一直都記得
它的變速器叫做Shimano 105
Shimano 105
我查了一下
它是Pro級的變速器
就可能Pro裡面的稍微入門款
可是這東西被他們講的像是比垃圾還不如的東西
就跟以前戰鬥陀螺
大家有時候會去比
有些型號
這個東西真的不行
然後大家會在那邊笑
我想說這真的是那種童年的感受
那我好奇心就起來了
我想說你們一直在像人家變速器這樣
你們的東西到底是有多屌
其實大家都是有辦法買得起的
這就是一定要互相喇叭要互相嘴一下
然後就開始在比啊
什麼變速器
如果這個Pro級要再往上上的話
其實你是可以上到三四倍的價格
我說那差別在哪
他說按起來比較輕
我不知道什麼
我就想到以前CD Pro 2的那個影片
就是他們跑去聽音響
然後在那邊互相歧視對方的音響
其實對外行人來說
就是我已經是聽不懂你們在講什麼
他說當你今天騎到一個極限
你真的很累的時候
那個變速器在換檔
它光是輕一點
或是它反應快一點
然後它可能就會造成一個
非常巨大的差別
可是我心中想的是
你們各位有去騎環法嗎
你們也沒有去騎環法
所以簡單來講就是
你可能不一定懂這個東西
但我後來也想懂
像我自己喝紅酒也是
我又不是說什麼
有拿到什麼四酒師的執照
或是說什麼有的沒有的
可是我一樣還是把
那種世界上最狂的酒
都跑來下一輪
你不一定要去參加這個比賽
可是你可以在外圍
然後去模擬一下
例如說他們去追求車價要輕量化
但是還有一個最低的要求
你也不可以無腦的輕量化
為什麼
因為你輕量化到某個程度
好像說有些比賽
你是不可以去比的
它有一定的重量
所以即便什麼探險車架
最好的輪俗跟功率計或什麼的
它還是要去符合比賽的標準
即便他們一輩子都不會去比這個比賽
然後這個有點像
也不是我在笑他們
就是以前我去打大魯閣棒球也是
我最早就是會想找那種怪力棒子
所以我就買了一堆那種超屌的鋁棒
特殊製造的
還要去上面要 engraving
要弄你的名字
然後客製的話
然後這個棒子
你就可以把球轟得超級無敵遠
然後很好揮
可是最後發現說
MLB的這些球員
為什麼他們都不用鋁棒
因為不可以用鋁棒
他們要用木棒
用鋁棒的話等於說是大人去玩小朋友的玩具很輕鬆就不小心把整個規則給玩爆掉他如果拿鋁棒的話可能隨便轟就是每一發都會轟住球場
所以他們拿木棒
就此我也去買了木棒
然後我還要去學他們的木棒是怎麼樣
還不夠
就是說這些職棒球員的木棒
我還要去訂製
我上面還一樣要去ingrave我的名字
我想說其實就跟這些
自身美少男美少女
在玩腳踏車差不多的一樣感受
以前對決是怎麼樣
這個戰鬥塑膠盤
然後跟公園的空地
大家那邊對
他們現在就會跑去
不知道什麼風貴嘴啊
然後還有另外一個冷水坑
我根本也沒有聽過這兩個地方
但聽完之後
我那時候就問
所以你們這腳踏車
可以配上風貴嘴嗎
配上風貴嘴好像是一個
蠻厲害的事情
然後什麼
最後的聖山是武林吧
我那時候聽起來是這樣子
我想說下次我要騎U-bike
我就跟你騎上去風貴嘴
我查了一下
我認為這不是辦不到的事情
因為風貴嘴沒有到很遠
他雖然可能不知道
海拔有一定的挑戰
但我覺得應該是有辦法
就是一樣
列如列宗
我騎不上去
瞧不起我這個心態
類似我跑10k一樣
我覺得應該是有辦法把它幹上去
我突然很有動機
想去做這件事情
但無零的話可能要想一下
無零可能太瘋狂
可是我記得之前也有看過人家
用那種超爛的腳踏車
然後記得就幹上去無零
反正總之就是看了
他們在腳踏車
自行車裡面的一個
那種熱情的分享之後
我覺得我應該也會弄一台自行車
只是我覺得時間
要再稍微等一下
因為弄下去
應該你就確定就變
你就是老人家了
你就變中年人了
所以我不希望這麼快去跟
雖然不知道有些人家
搞不好把34歲當成是中年
我不想那麼快去跟我的年少道別
所以先放在那邊
大家知道說
反正你要去搞一個最屌的腳踏車
就三五十萬其實還OK
就是差不多一瓶高級紅酒的價格
這個是我們可以接受的
我就要去弄一台腳踏車
我要看看你們的東西到底多厲害
吹成這樣
就像我之前聽人家
我每次聽人家吹東西
我就會覺得說到底有多屌
然後我就會跳下去
然後跳下去之後
其實就會發現就是這樣子
但你會很羨慕這些人
他們是超級的投入
他不像我們以前玩正套陀螺
或是以前會玩那個毒鞘
好像每個地方叫不一樣的東西
反正就是你用拇指還是食指夾起來
然後要把它蓋到別人的上面
你就贏了
然後大家會玩到很瘋狂
什麼上面塗一些立可白
讓它厚度變高之類的
但對我來說就是
我就是玩一輪之後
我一直都是沒有辦法深入那種
所以我也很羨慕
他們可以拿這個去吵架
然後去曬優越
去嘴炮人家
因為這一定是非常快樂
這是一種那種歸屬感
雖然長大了玩具也變大了但是錢包變空可是心中是滿足的想贏想炫耀的心情都還是就像是童年那樣子
然後找到一群人
可以跟你在那邊嘴炮
感覺是一個蠻好玩的東西
昨天也跟這些人談心
我就說最近這個盤面
其實人與人的信賴不見
我們講了一兩個月以上
跟奧德賽演的一樣
宙斯法則已經不被遵守
所長停的東西隔天不繼續跑
你這樣會變怎樣
以後大家就知道了
我就騙你所長停
然後我隔天也丟
就是你要開始去猥瑣別人
你讓整個環境變得很猥瑣
就類似對外有些東西他們開始內捲
大家開始在互相算計
其實最終就是大家已經下去了
所以我覺得一個正常成長的經濟
一個好的地方
大家不應該這樣子互相暗算
就是不要去耍一些小聰明
市場沒有辦法我知道
因為大家都是匿名的
你最多看到分點
現在大家也都很聰明
知道分點要放在總公司裡面要匯播
所以你也抓不到人
所以他們就互相猥瑣
可是有些在現實生活中
還是會被猥瑣
你知道我昨天就是跟我們家人開了一個小會
我就說9月11號謝家家持日
從此之後我們家不可以再被欺負
因為我們很認真去盤點
那個破口是這樣
就是剛好有一個朋友最近我帶去品酒會
然後他也蠻喜歡的
然後開始想要去探索自己的口味
我就一次推他好幾個業務
然後讓他去買
然後結果人家一去買
我前面還跟他科普一大堆
美國的納帕大概長什麼樣子
高價低價
然後可能是因為他的年份
或者說有些是傳奇的酒瓶蘋果
所以價格是怎麼樣
反正你只要大概買什麼位置
就OK什麼的
講了半天
就身為一個過來人
而且身為一個花書超級多學費的人
我覺得我應該很有資格去教他這個東西
結果JK他跑去問一樣的業務
還是我他媽介紹的
他一買他的價格就比我便宜
他直接就買比我便宜
然後回來問我說你買的比我貴
你知道那時候行中超級不爽
簡單來說就是
如果沒有人跟我講這件事情
只有人在暗示說你那東西可能買貴
我連查都懶得去查
可是人家直接把證據丟到你臉上了
這就是說怎麼講
你強迫我一定要去面對了
所以我想說對阿
為什麼你他媽你才能買第一次
為什麼你可以買的比我便宜
我就立刻就跑去找我的酒商業務
但我的酒商業務很多人
就講到這個時候
有些搞不好聽眾就比較要覺得說
怎麼發生什麼事
好像是一竿子打翻譯傳了
沒有因為其實我就找很多人都會下單
因為每個東西
每個人有的品是不一樣的
其實是代理的或什麼的
其實我下法都是蠻大方的
我自己覺得
至少可能七位數那都是很基本的
買下去之後
也都不會再去跟你講價
不會拿人家報價單案跟你比
然後再來就是
一般我跟你說我要買
我就立刻就匯款給你
我也不會等說
你等我下午
我上線碰到
好像有一次上線碰到
國泰轉帳200-300萬
碰到之後我就怎樣
我就多帳號轉給你
我也不用跟你講說什麼
我就再等個什麼一兩天
反正我一直都覺得
我是一個蠻阿沙利的人
可是你們怎麼可以這樣子對我
不可以這樣
人與人的信任很重要
你在股票互稿就算了
因為你藏在分點後面
可是現實生活之中
每個人都是有頭有臉的
你是有公司行好的
你不可以不把你的信用
當成是一個很重要的事情
你不可以因為說這個客人不會比價
然後他就是很阿薩利的跟你買
所以想說他應該不用折扣吧
別人都有
因為別人他不確定他會不會再回來
他不確定他會不會去比價
所以他就給他一個很實惠的價格
然後我就不給
他就不給我
然後甚至我自己去問的時候
還會跟我講說先生
你可能要累積到幾瓶才有
我想說你當我智障
人家買1萬多塊的東西
你給他打折
我給你買了破百萬的
那你還跟我講說我要累積
你現在就是怎樣
就是覺得說我就是盤子好敲是嗎
我都已經來正面confirm的
你還敢這樣跟我講話
那很簡單
以後就不會跟你做生意
我也沒有那麼無聊
不會上Flads工審或是貼線洞
我不做這種事情
我覺得成年人世界
就是我們不去指教別人
我們就是去選擇
可是其實我會覺得
去措施掉一些客人會是蠻可惜的
因為我也有我的朋友
我的朋友可能也都跟我一樣
有類似的消費力
你怎麼會覺得你可以這樣子對我
你怎麼會覺得這樣做是沒問題的
然後剛剛也跟這些資深美少男
美少女聊到他們說
其實這個社會很多人真的都是這樣子
他知道你就是很阿薩利的買單
然後像他們自己的業界有遇到
他看到你怎麼quote客戶這個價格
怎麼會是這個價格
他說沒關係啦
這個大哥他平常怎麼
你怎麼會有這個心態
但後來發現說很多人都有這種心態
很多人的心態是
我不知道我有點想把它稱為是難民心態
他們就會覺得
這樣說好了
你不一定是家裡窮才會成為難民
像我們家裡就是一般的普通家庭
可是就不會有這種
就是超級難民的心態
而且我甚至發現說
可能蠻多那種乾苦上來的
更不會這樣子做
反而就是生活不錯的人
他們會怎樣去猥瑣別人
因為他們會不知道
就是不把別人的錢當錢
我就會覺得說反正他不會問
我就給他某一個那種定價
也不會去給他折扣
反正他還是會回來
這個是不對的
因為其實這個世界的信用是很重要的
就是最後都會在外面流傳
然後即便人家不會去攻審你或什麼的
可是你調了一些重要的客人
然後這些客人他們也會有一群
就是跟他一樣有這樣消費力的客人
這個真的是因小失大我覺得就蠻可惜的反正最近遇到了一些這樣的事情然後後來就跟家人講說我們從此不要再被虛了你知道很多人他跟我們收錢都這樣我們不去比價然後接著都是別人來跟我們講
還知道說你應該會有一些rebet
應該會有什麼
就算其實你給我什麼介紹人的費用
我也不會跟你收
我也懶得回去跟你兌換
但你要讓我知道說我有
你不可以說什麼
他們感覺不需要
然後就不給我
然後我也發現說我老婆去坐臉
也是媽的給人家虛
就是為什麼大家都在虛我們
所以這個世界我真的覺得
我們要重振人與人的信任
不只是在股票市場裡面
你開銀手你就是要漲
你有好消息你就是要漲
你不可以每次都用利多出鏡來搞人家
你說利多出鏡的話
NVIDIA跟TSM他們利多發幾次了
也沒有完全出鏡
就是還是會一直上去
但如果說你整天都想要蹭利多
然後把大家灌爆
以後你這個股票就沒有朋友
大家都不會想回來玩
我會講給蠻多我們同業新有77N
有些公司真的專門這樣子搞人
公司派也一起配合
這個是不對的事情
因為傳出去不好聽
以後你真的沒有朋友
差不多這樣一個感受
好接下來我們就來聊一下
最近的Apple發表會
針對iPhone新一代的Pro Max
我覺得不用花太多時間去琢磨
因為基本上就是更新更強更厲害
差不多永遠都是這樣的一個pattern
但這次我對於Apple的iPhone Duo
我覺得非常的感興趣
沒有意外的話
也會在第一時間就直接去入手一台
而且我覺得它令我非常驚訝的是
它的價格其實就是比Fore 8
再稍微的貴一點點而已
所以我稍微看一下市場的Consensus
大家本來估計的價格應該是高蠻多的
所以理論上這一台折疊機
應該會賣得比想像中好
因為其實本來大家預計的價格是更高的
然後最後面是一個相對實惠的價格
雖然說如果你今天是把規格上滿的話
它一台就是十幾萬
十幾萬以上的東西
有些人已經不會把它當成是手機了
就可能會把它視為是某一種
反正你無法用CP值去衡量它
它是一種信仰的產物
或者說你真的有需要的人
你會去買它
當然我就是那種會去買它的人
類似說其實Fold我也是直接去搞一個最強大的
那我不會去做可能捧黑彩B這種事情
就是我覺得以安卓系的手機來講
我覺得Fold系列我用的是蠻高興的
然後特別是我目前最喜歡的點是
因為我會玩手遊然後會課金
那個尼基跟中二那個禮包出來
我一定都是買到爆炸
因為經濟場要用那個戰壓去壓別人
然後有些人就整天想要來打我
所以我就是課到人家沒有辦法打我
所以課金這件事情
其實還是使用安卓機
是有很大的一個優勢
這是我覺得安卓機目前最強大的部分因為我只要去使用裡面的Google商店買東西它會給我點數然後那個點數我目前是已經形成一個永動機了就是我會去買尼基的商品然後接著會換到點數
點數我就拿去換中二
因為它500點的Google點數就可以換300塊
所以非常的划算
我就用這樣子成為一個永動機
然後持續的去刷課金
除此之外
就是一些安卓的工作介面
我覺得它是蠻有用的
而且它可以切更多畫面
它可以切到超過兩個以上
我自己使用的體驗上
是沒有什麼太大的問題
這次的iPhone 2的話
它應該就是以雙螢幕去做為設計
所以如果去切介面也是雙介面
有些人就會去做一些硬體的比較
就是說到底可能
Apple到底是挑戰哪
為什麼它比較貴
然後或者說會有蠻多
最常聽到的主張就是安卓系的粉絲
會說這個安卓找到做了
但這個是一個很沒有意義的辯論
那就類似說你知道任天堂
每次用的硬體都是
他媽的狗都不要硬體嗎
大家都知道這件事情嗎
大家知道任天堂在家機
他們用的東西都是那種最成熟
最鳥蛋的東西
可是無法改變的是他們有非常強大的IP
跟很好的一個使用體驗
所以其實在Apple這邊是類似的道理
就是他用的東西
你一定可以在不管是Google的手機
或是Samsung或是什麼的
他們可能很早以前就是做過類似的實驗
或是那個腳鏈他早就做了
他可能已經沒有很明顯可以看到折或什麼
那不重要
重點不是說誰先做
科技的重點不是誰先做
就像是你現在不會去糾結說
到底誰是第一個把LM模型做出來的
干我屁事啊
就对你要科普是OK
只是我们想要比的就是现在谁最厉害
所以这才是真正的重点
就如果说你只是想要弹枝想要喇叭
那当然是另外一回事
只是在实际的应用
或者是我们工作的一些导入
我要去买谁的股票
那个不是说什么谁先做就是比较厉害
是谁可以把这个东西发扬广大
那个是我们会比较在意的点
这一次我觉得iPhone Duo
它把折叠的效果是处理的很好
虽然你还是可以在一些评测的影片里面
会有注意到有小小的折痕
但這個折痕就是符合
我們可能在幾年前跟大家有聊過
蘋果他就是會等到一個技術
相對成熟的時候才會去做介入
因為他不希望給他的消費者
有一些類似那種拓荒的體驗
這個東西可能是一個實驗品
還不夠成熟的
雖然Vision Pro有點這樣的一個味道
所以也賣不好
可能後續也會被人家殺掉就沒了
但是在他們的一些成熟產品上面
我覺得他們是非常小心的在推進
按照這樣子一個原則
那他最後的賣點
我覺得會是各種觸控上的體驗
必須得講其實蠻多人去低估iPhone的一點
就是說Apple相關產品的一點是
它其實是在操作上面非常的直覺然後再來是有很多很聰明的軟硬整合的巧思這個是就叫做我自己也有去使用安卓機我可能有時候去點一些東西我覺得我比較難點到
或者說它會飄掉
或者介面搞得太複雜
可蘋果就會把它包得很簡單
而且是很直覺
然後是符合一般人日常使用
會想像它該是什麼樣的一個樣子
它比較不用去繞路或什麼的
這是蘋果它強大的點
所以它去用更強大的UI UX去包裝
然後結果它價格只有稍微貴一點點
我認為它的銷量會很不錯
就是應該會超出大家的預期
只是它會有一個蠻主要的
需要驗證的點是
我們知道摺接手機
目前看起來在中國
它算是一個非常重要的市場
只是中國最近的消費
是很明顯的有降級
不然說大家去注意到一些
精品品牌所開出來的成績
會注意到他們對於精品的一個追求
已經沒有像過去這麼瘋狂的
然後一些消費油在降軌
不然說像一些華香北的整形機
其實是賣得很好
所以我覺得還是要看中國市場是怎麼樣
如果今天是站在牆外的角度來看的話
我會認為這支手機理論上要賣得很好
但它算起來價格終究是比較高一點
所以可能最後面就是靠中國市場這邊去做一個驗證
只是如果現在我要去壓住跟猜測的話
我會覺得摺疊手機的整個銷量
應該會有一個蠻顯著的上修
至於一般的iPhone可能就不用去做太多的想像
我認為就跟過往是差不多
但可以期待的是可能折疊手機的市場
在這一代產品有機會會去把他的
整個market share去拉高
在整個手機市場裡面
那令我比較意外的是
相關的一些components
像腳鏈的話
台系的廠商3376新日行
他就是裡面最主要的一個player之一
還有美系的像是安芬奴
只是在3376這邊會稍微複雜一點
因為他畢竟要去跟鴻海拆賬
所以這個股價也是屬於是相對難掌握的東西
但是我們蠻確定這個產品
它是有major share
它在裡面是做很大
那個鑿鏈其實做的算是蠻好的
就是它有點類似以前Fold的比較早期
我記得後來它把它改掉了
就它那個鑿鏈是可以多角度的
它不是只有打開跟關起來
它也可以弄成像是小帳篷
你可以射鬧鐘
然後有一個那種溫馨的小燈光
其實有蠻多技術考驗在背後
那只是我自己蠻意外的一點是
我本來以為說像這種第一代的產品
剛推出它應該會有很好的margin
或是獲利
只是後來在業界的朋友是講說
好像沒有
蘋果還是壓制的蠻嚴格的
可能也相當程度的去解釋
為什麼理論上一些新的科技的導路
會至少讓它走一個
可能比較大的波段
但他好像很早以前
他在消息 rumor的時候就先去走
然後這也就是一直在橫盤
有可能是這樣的一個原因
其實除非是後面有出現
蠻明顯的上修
他會去改變這件事情
但是如果你轉頭去看一些
射頻相關的元件的話
然後在美系廠商這邊
你可以去注意到
射頻元件廠其實蠻多動起來
現在有一個說法就是
因為遮疊機大家已經會提早去想像
他有可能在後面
會有蠻好的銷量跑出來
然後會去帶動
整個市場可能更加去接受這樣的一個產品
然後在摺疊的設計的設計上面
會跟一般的手機會有一定程度的出入
然後再來可能價格也會變得比較好一點
所以有人去買單這樣子的一個題材
但我現在自己的感受是
我不會想要去看消費性的題材
因為消費性的題材
你在怎麼樣成長你都打不贏AI
所以我自己只是大概跟大家分享一下
它主要裡面的一些供應鏈的亮點
大家會去看到
只是我覺得資金上
應該是不會有太多資金想要去讀這個東西
因為外面腐蝕皆是
Ear on year是可能100%以上的東西
那我為什麼會想要去挑選一個
就是Ear on year可能不會太好
然後甚至是我知道
它今天走到第二代第三代
蘋果一定會去把你幹掉的東西
特別是像我們前面看到C1的
那個貓特朗晶片
然後現在已經走到C2了
可以想像像高通在後面
可以扮演的角色
一定就是慢慢的被擊掉
所以蘋果它厲害在
它有辦法在這個供應鏈的管理上
然後最終是讓優勢
然後跟利潤全部都跑到自己身上
然後幫它做東西的人
其實早期大家會去搶這樣的生意
因為你知道蘋果就是有量
只是最終下很多人就知道說
你去配合蘋果的話
你價格可能被壓到死掉
然後接著他又會再去養一個惡公對付你
所以其實有蠻多人已經開始意識到說
我們不可以只做蘋果的生意
或甚至是有些廠商就是
他寧願不要蘋果的生意
因為發現這個生意做下去不長久
然後人家在供應鏈上的掌握實在是太厲害了
所以其實蘋果我也越來越覺得
它的那個垂直整合的能力很強大
就是讓我想到特斯拉的感覺
就是有一些關鍵的零件
或者說價格最好的最缺的
他可能就自己把它卡起來
他把它握得非常的好
所以變成說其他人都只能夠幫他打工
其實我們在特斯拉也是注意到這樣的一個邏輯
他們甚至在SpaceX裡面
有些那種PCB他自己打
他自己打他自己組
他不要讓別人去做
因為他發現說這個東西我可以自己弄之類的
所以大概是這樣的一個狀態
但是我是相信說這台手機在後面的表現
應該會蠻好的可能當然有些人會想去注意相關題材這就要稍微的去明白一下因為市場裡面的錢是有限的當今天市場上有很多有非常暴力成長性的東西那就未必
你的東西有成長
但他未必會想把錢放到你的東西裡面
因為畢竟類似說注意力是有限的
我知道下面有很多很好看的作品
可是當今天你上檔的時間是
外面有一些強檔片
你要跟諾蘭正面對決的話
即便你的電影可能拍得不錯
你的票房也不一定會太好
這個是大家可能在投資上面
要稍微去注意的點
不然其實整個看下來
我覺得是蠻喜歡的
你甚至可以直接就單純的
我覺得像蘋果應該就是有機會
會再有
也不敢講說股價一定會漲多少
可是至少在過去
大家是比較看它沒有
覺得它可能在AI時代
要被變化什麼的
然後現在越來越多的嘗試跟證明
都在在的去佐證說
這家公司它有辦法
把很多的客人留在這
甚至會獲得更多的新客
特別是在這一波的記憶體漲價裡面
它反而產生巨大的一個優勢
因為別人可能漲價就賠錢了
然後接著它漲價
它不一定會賠錢
它還是毛利可以守得相當的不錯
接著用相對實惠的價格
可以獲取一些新客
這在後續的轉換效應上
都有蠻多的想像空間
就是我先把客人拉進來
用我的platform 用我的東西
接著AI在看怎麼算
有些我用自己的Foundation AI
有些我用別人的
都是後面是可以談的東西
特別是我們開始去相信
大型的語言模型
它有可能會變成是一種 commodity的狀況
特別是在日常的應用上面
我們當然不會去講說尖端科技
什麼蛋白質折疊
開發新藥它會變 commodity
不會那個一定還是會付出巨額的錢
去換取潛在的巨額的報酬
譬如說日常問說食譜怎麼樣
問說SHIMANO 105這個變速器是怎麼樣
問說風貴嘴跟冷水坑哪個人適合去
像這樣子的一些日常用途
它都不用走到最先進的模型
然後我覺得後來掌握通路的人
在這一塊應該就可以相當程度的獲得一定程度的價值分配
大概這樣
接下來我們來稍微的看一下 Oracle 這次的一些說法
那要我們不會針對太多的細節去做評論
就抓一些重點
那首先不用出錢的魔術
像目前就是由客戶預付
不然說去借客戶的錢
然後跟 BYOH 也就是客戶去自帶硬體
然後 Oracle 去收貸款費以及供應商融資
借 NVIDIA 或是設備商的錢
所以其實跟NVIDIA之前的玩法有點像
一筆生意收兩日前
同時是供應商金主然後又是靠這些訂單去成長在稱頻時期没有太大的问题但如果说后面要扭转的话这个需求是有可能会被自己的融资
放大有一个虚胖的一个现象
但一样我们不是末日博士
我们不会针对未来可能会爆炸的剧本
提早去做太多的剖析
大家自己在心中有底就好
所以这就是Oracle可以去杠杆别人的一些小魔术
再来在过去的一段时间
四年的旧卡反而发生了涨价20%的情形
所以这个其实就是像是黄文鑫讲的
fungible, durable, rentable
这个东西可能没有像之前的一些空方的论述
是说有可能在未来一段时间会高速的折旧
那一样这些东西都是有可能在反转之后会出事情的
因为现在是这样需求很旺
反转之后有可能会掉很快
再来他们也提到说
目前电力跟许可会是关键的瓶颈
有一个17英里的管线
被否决了两次
我就不让他过
再来有另外一个州
要求一个A减的信品
不然要你去递交70亿的信用状
同时大量的选民反对
所以这也正式的宣告
特别是大家最近该有看到
Bernie Sanders去反AI电脑Center
跟AOC越来越多的报导
贴文疯狂的去发
所以AI基础建设
现在已经进入了
地方政治的一个阶段
也就是说地方的政治
是有可能
特別是假設
我自己在想像
就是共和黨假設後來的選舉
稍微失利的話
民主黨聲勢上來
就有可能會讓整個資料中心的建制
會出現一些變數
我還是認為
以美國民主黨之間的說法
特別是Bernie Sanders
我一直都不知道
Bernie Sanders這樣子的各種論述
大家去看他X
我覺得就任何名理人
或是有在外面工作的
應該都會覺得
反正就老玩天亂講話
就很奇怪
他的很多說法是非常奇怪的
这个人就感觉他的工作就是去分配别人的财产
然后去阻止别人的发展
这样子也可以获得选票
然后跟很多的支持
没有办法
所以我一向都认为
就像你去推这些先进的科技
其实你让大家要去共同的分享到一些利益
这是非常重要的
如果说真的就只有少数人赚钱的话
民主的制度就是票多的赢
少数的赚钱的人
你投票还是有可能会投不赢
大多數相對剝奪
即便他們自己本身可能也是實質受惠
但他們就覺得看你們賺這麼多錢
好像我都沒有分到然後再外加一些Propaganda說可能對水對對什麼東西空氣的污染啊或是你的電力成分漲效即便有太多證據去阻振根本不是這樣
但你都可能會對這些選民造成影響
然後去投下對Data Center的一個反對票
所以我覺得這個是後面
可能也會稍微要去注意的一個利空
那也因為說電力系統
會有比較卡關的一些可能性
所以呢
表後的供電
然後不然說他們自己去搞那種
活塞式的或是燃氣
或是有的沒有的
甚至是太陽能
最近像Tesla這邊就有一個傳說是這樣
就是對外放出了大量的太陽能的訂單
也導致一些相關的供應鏈跑起來
這些可能都是在後面的一些solution
就是如果你想要去建置這些
大家都知道現在非常賺錢的AI Data Center
上集還剛聊到
像Blockcon直接提出
一年就可以回本
最大的問題其實是
要在法規跟電力這邊要去過關
所以与其去等人家
说不定有蛮多这些大企业就会选择
我自己用硬干的方式
看怎么样
自己去做突破
所以像Oracle这季的表现
其实都还蛮好的
然后针对一些关键
大家会有疑虑的地方
也做出了一些说明
在它的营收部分是年增了30%
那未履约的合约呢
RPO有6600多亿
所以上修全年
状况都很好
但一样
其他的整体市场的环境
有点比方说
利多也不一定会涨
因为就是比较处于震荡的一个情形
還是希望早點改出這個狀態
但目前的現況就是這樣
最後再稍微講一下
因為我們上集是聊到Google
在GlobensX的一個會議上面
所提到的東西
後來的一天
Huck也去了GS的會議
也有一些說法
我們就直接快速的講結論就好
就是說他目前心中的想法是怎麼樣
他認為
避鎖模型最後的贏家是寡頭
甚至就是一個人
就是只有一組人會獲得勝利
然後他會獲得最大的一個價值
這個我是先稍微的打一個問號
我自己是覺得說應該還是會偏向
至少像它這種雙頭的模式是很有機會的
Amphilopic跟OpenAI輪流的超車
應該是在後來一段時間會看到的
然後再來就是其實AI它並不是像大家想像的
就是你可能用其中一個模型
你就可以什麼事情都做到
隨著大家越來越熟悉AI模型之後也知道
AI模型它在各個領域
其實都會有它強大的模型存在
所以有可能後面會呈現那種特化的版本
我是相信說可能在某些頂尖領域
他就是只用某一種模型
這是對的
但因為領域非常多
所以應該都還是有很多空間
他有提到一個蠻關鍵的數字
目前這些閉鎖式的
你可能投1,000億是可以賺1,300億
如果你今天是開放式權重的模型
你可能投1,000億能夠賺300億
所以大家都懷疑這樣的一個經濟模式
是不是會work
這個其實可以呼應到
我們過去幾集有稍微的提一下
簡單來說這些AI的錢
除了外面消費者給的之外
就是這些大型語言模型的廠商
他們去對市場
對於一些股東所募資到的錢
他把他投入這些設備
當然還有一些那種Seller Financing的東西
那所以呢
以目前來說我是認為啦
之所以可能沒有辦法看到一些
價值的產生的主因是因為還沒有辦法很明確的去定義說
到底是哪個領域然後最後面會由這些開源的模型去做
所以開源模型下比較偏向是
簡單來說他還是有很多錢去投資
因為大家還是持續的相信
這些東西也有可能在後面會蹦出一些職位
雖然領投資是必守模型
主要付錢的是兩大模型廠商
但後面隨著我覺得劃分越來越清楚之後
像前面所提到的稍微簡單一點的應用
可能就交給開放全充的模型去做
到時候那邊產出來的價值應該就會拉上去一些
然後隨著硬體建置的成本開始拉flat之後
後面的我覺得價值產出會開始慢慢出現
但現在當然是很明顯
最主要的價值是在這些全員模型這邊
可是全員模型他們壓力也很大
因為他賺到的錢就要立刻再投出去
而且還是要持續的募資
信用的狀態也不是很好
而且隨時都有可能
如果真的像Huck所講的話
只有可能寡頭可以贏
其他爆炸
你知道爆炸是很嚴重的
可能只要有一兩家
也不用到兩家
可能一家爆炸
對於整個市場的論述跟供需
都會造成巨大的影響
所以就是大家一起爆炸
只要有一家爆炸
我覺得市場就是一起爆炸
所以會傾向相信說
他講的劇本比較不會發生
就是會往那個傾向去
只是有一些細部的東西
要稍微的把它講清楚
不然如果真的是發生他講的劇本
他自己也是一個最大的受害
差不多這樣的一個感受
以上就是這集節目跟大家分享
接下來我們要進入Q的部分
第一位KT後
孟公祉卡您好
想問您一關於功能性訓練
您有推薦的說嗎
我目前都是問教練
然後二和台通成城是怎麼認識的
好像是共同朋友介紹的
我也沒有印象
但我記得第一次見面好像是
就見到他跟呱吉
都是第一次見面
三如果有天諾亞或安哥
對於你和Lisa安排的活動不再感興趣不斷跳針喊著好無聊您會怎麼做呢不是想求正確答案就是想聽聽看不同的人的不同做法其實目前諾亞就已經會很常喊無聊
而且後來真的會發現孩子不可以偷生
就是他跟我一樣
有時候情緒會比較跳一點
所以他可能早上還在跟我們講說
要找他的朋友來家裡
那下午呢
就是朋友玩一下下
他就會默默的跑過來說
爸爸 可不可以叫他回家
他就會希望他的朋友趕快回家
他覺得夠了
他覺得夠了就讓人家回家
然後晚上的時候還會在那邊念
就說下次不要讓朋友來我家什麼
因為他來我家的話
我就沒有時間自己玩什麼之類的
那他有一次玩具沒有收好
我們就跟他說
你要這樣子的話
那下次我們就可能沒有辦法讓朋友來你家
因為你看你招待人家來玩
然後你都不把自己的東西收好
就耶
他直接給我他媽的耶
就他就覺得說他不想要
所以他是一個很有主見的孩子
非常有自己的一個想法
一般來說我們會稍微的順著他一點
就是他想要幹嘛我們就讓他做
但是如果說你完全的順著你的孩子
那你就是沒有做好父母的本物
你還是要做一些
因為小朋友畢竟腦袋沒有建構好
所以你認為是對的事情
你要讓他做
出去運動出去走一走
還是要讓他去
所以即便不喜歡
還是會把他拐出去
但是我們比較不用強迫或是用罵的
就是用右拐的方式
你現在去的話
待會就給你一些什麼好處
或是你回來就可以稍微玩一下switch之類的
目前會用這樣的方式去推
再來說第四
平常會對Lisa做親密的舉動嗎
比如說出門抱一下之類的
結果老婆超像老人家
她就是不太喜歡那種年輕人的一些互動
她都會說very gay
就是不要對我做什麼gay
這麼cringy的事情
她會有很多自己的想法
那就對啊
我會故意為了讓她生氣
就抱一下親一下
但她就會不要不要
但有時候她自己氣氛對情緒好的時候
自己又會跑過來
所以不一定啦
不一定
沒有那個...怎麼講...就是自視的走法
那下面一位
夢夢 猛攻猛攻
我男友南港胖虎每集都會聽五六七八遍
感覺很閒 對你有夠著迷
即使如此他絕對九日生日我還是來留言
雖然過了幾天拜託有機會念到
可能會愛我多一點
其中肌肉猛男的聲音送到四個字
生日快樂
下面一位 妮虎
嗨老公今天來分享一下
我乾女兒真的超可愛的啦
動不動就乾爹喜帆尼
討千千抱抱
甚至會送珍藏的貼紙
真的會被融化
對了我上次說找另外一半會捐一季的薪水快樂寶貝啦小弟自己辦事不利還沒有達到願望但貪心的想再請觀音團實踐兩個願望第一個願望是後天4歲生日的乾女兒雨娜寶貝
健康快樂長大
遇到很多好人貴人
第二個願望祝老公
可以至少有一個女兒
每天來融化一下
不過小弟最近手頭比較緊
7月到現在持續做動能
還開始打融資
YTD從300多%掉到15%
那雖然相信今年還可以打回新高
瓜哥投資5年都贏大盤
但還是先保守一點
慢慢捐一個月的薪水來獻祭愛您
非常感謝在Year Today的報酬大爆炸
還是願意要捐錢
甚至是要幫我實現願望
非常感謝你
希望你可以順利的找到你的另外一半
你的乾女兒可以健康快樂的長大
只是還是要稍微的多嘴一下
從300多%掉15%
雖然你過去都贏大盤
雖然你還是正的
但這樣的一個drawdown
其實代表著你可能是用
我覺得可能是太高風險的方式在做操作
當然富貴險中求
你很多那種高風險的操作
也是隱含的你有可能會瞬間暴富
只是長遠下來
我們一般是不會建議大家有這樣子的一個報酬曲線
就是暴漲暴跌或什麼的
因為後來趨近爆炸的機率應該是會高蠻多的
所以還是建議你盡量要稍微的穩當一點
會比較好
那下面一位
夢遊先生安安夢公指南公
最近無聊又來重看獵人
夢公知道紐克星是
其實是紐約到過來嗎?
不知道
吸索到過來就是鑰匙
挂號台語
窩金就是Wardgene
不知道為什麼我剛剛要認真看
這媽還講幹話
前陣子聽潘董在財報狗節目
聊到AIDAPTIVE的降本效果極佳
台幣兩三百萬的投入
可以節省50M左右
很適合大部分的中小企業
先期AI的導入來放量之後
商業模式可能會改賣售權
變得有點像SI的味道
這部分有什麼有趣的訊息可以分享嗎
如果還不太能聊也沒關係
反正還是愛您一萬年
祝何家平安健康
這個是不能夠聊
因為那時候Adaptive剛出的時候
我就已經去群聯參訪
在一兩年前的節目
就有跟大家聊到這樣的一個解方
非常感謝當時的林偉博士
還有他們的CEO
以及一些快樂好夥伴
潘董也是沒有在現場
但是也跟我視訊
然後還送了我一本他簽名的書
那時候稍微講他的故事
其實你現在回頭看
你就會覺得這家公司蠻真知灼見的他們在最早的時候也不是說他們開創出某種東西因為畢竟他們做Nam Flash起家的公司做Controller然後自己又有很多顆粒
所以過去賺了蠻多錢
就是說他們手邊有這樣的一個產品
所以就丟出一個問題
有沒有可能
我們用自己手邊的產品
去幫大家做到地端模型的
不管是一些fine tune 或者說推論
我可以幫大家省下很多錢
你也比較不會卡工一點
雖然事後回頭看
就是NAND其實也是蠻卡的
價格也漲得很兇
當然就相較於寸土寸金的什麼HBM
SRAM然後接著DRAM
我有沒有可能用NAND去幫你做這件事情
其實最近就已經越來越多討論
跟一些實務的做法
就是我把KP cash往外丟
我丟到NAND
我丟到甚至Storage Rack裡面去
開始去切分這些模型
他們是很早就在提這個概念
就是我去幫你切
我把東西切一切之後
然後用我們的硬體做訓練
可以幫你省下非常多錢
不管是在硬體採購
那抑或是
你知道你公司如果開始去走應用
這個其實就是我們前面聊到話題的一個隱身
如果你是持續的去推建造型的模型
沒有辦法
你還是得加入邪漏競技場
繼續的去往前衝
然後去堆那些硬體
但後面就開始劃分出一些
可能企業日常的應用
這個東西是
我沒有必要每次都上雲
我一直上雲的話
老闆先把我抓一吊一頓
你說AI可以讓大家省錢
結果用AI反而就讓一些公司搞到快破產
你看Uber那個帳單直接爆發
除非就是說有些最尖端最前端的東西
你必須要上雲之外
其實有一些應用都已經開始
會往地端的方向去推
這時候去使用
他們又相對容易入手的硬體
然後搭配你這樣的一個思維
降本真效讓運算在地端
其實這個combo是蠻厲害的
我上次更新大概是半年一年前
我記得他們有跟Adventec
就研華有一些合作
我是不知道後面推的怎麼樣
但其實這個idea是蠻好的
重點還是回到那時候一兩年前的說法
就是要看有多少客戶會去採用
有時候你走太前面的話
曲線ramp上還是需要一點時間
但我覺得整個概念是蠻好的
確實可能會從一個
最早大家講說是controller廠
然後就越做越廣
他們有一些高速傳輸的solution
在他公司的各種布局
其實真的都蠻廣的
你說會不會有點像SI
也不一定
就可能會找一個夥伴去幫他推
不會自己去推他就負責去做設備而已
應該會這樣
因為SI的話蠻多鳥屎的事情
你知道群聯工程師是很貴的
這些開發工程師
應該兩三百萬年薪以上
所以
應該比較不會去做那種幫客戶巴斯把尼亞
我自己猜測就是這樣
就應該會找夥伴去做搭手
所以這個東西確實是有一些機會
下面一位
Miss Cho
無敵感謝孟公Chika的節目
才智有趣兼具好好聽
最重要是讓我跟學長變熟
一開始愛您愛您的開玩笑
變成了愛你然後最近結婚了
孟公是我們的媒人
謝謝您愛您
雖然我跟老公的相愛過程很坎坷
之前很Emo到私訊孟公抒發一波
有點像是祈禱的概念
那雖然還在調試
但恍然大悟想好好把握
現在得來不易的幸福
麻煩夢公幫我跟老公說
兩週年快樂要好好疼老婆
讓老婆放心
PS我最愛的男人第一名是我老公
第二名是夢公第三名是童神
你怎麼都喜歡這種非主流怪咖
你老公會不會也是一個怪小
再來講說祈禱其實這個蠻常發生的
就是我的IG下有蠻多是
你感覺之前他也不一定是要你真的回答什麼
他會講說希望聽夢公跟我講一下是怎麼樣的感受
但我知道他沒有要聽
他只是想找個地方講話
那我就會去順應大家
反正你也不確定我有沒有看到
但是講完之後
有時候你自己就舒服
或是你腦中就開了
反正我如果給你feedback
就讓你整個吹奏一池春水
所以對我就擔任一個垃圾
也別講垃圾箱
就信箱
反正你們要寫東西
你們隨便寫沒有玩
不要傳那種奇怪的東西
你知道有些人會把
我IG的對話欄
當成是他去存一些
你知道
算有時候我也是看的蠻開心
就是他會把一些影片
存在那邊很北蘭
他覺得不錯的
他可能不知道存在哪
他就存在跟我的對話裡面
對啦反正就是有很多那種延伸的應用
類似剛剛前面講到Adaptive
你也不知道大家最後沒有怎麼樣用
說不定一些那種延伸應用是
產出最多的應用
總之只要對大家有所貢獻
我覺得都是還蠻開心
但希望你們可以一切順利
下面一位Winter Chen
愛大您好
我和男友在新竹開麻辣香果
您的節目常常讓我們在打掃的時候不孤單
也很謝謝您無私的分享
今年開店第四年 因為店面有些問題不想續約了
一方面也覺得父母年紀很大 想陪在他們身邊
希望您可以祝福我們順利把新竹的店面點讓出去
並在台北找到適合的店面繼續營業
如果有些順利 我會捐3萬塊給i2協會
那我是您的粉絲 希望您用自己原始的聲音
祝他未來一切順利股票賺大錢
那自己祝了
也祝福你們一家平安順行年
非常感謝Winter
希望你們可以順利的在台北找到店面
並且順利的把
把新竹的店顶出去一切平安下面有位Lizzi Chung不知道現在留言來不來得及聽到孟公講貓咪的故事居然眼眶泛紅是正常的嗎
我覺得孟公也不用太自責
至少比起在街頭流浪
有一個安穩可以生活的地方
他應該就很開心的
我非常感謝這位妹妹的留言
其實有時候就會想比較多
類似
你知道Choco他有幾個兄弟姐妹
好像是三隻黑的兩隻白的
我們都是在宜蘭的休公所認領的
後來就發現說他的姐妹們
都被送去了美國跟加拿大
反正就是有愛媽在中間牽線
最後面他們都去美國加拿大
穿回來的照片發現說
有一個坐在Sup上面戴著墨鏡超酷
另外一個全身穿裝備跑去滑雪
我們就想說我們是不是耽誤了這隻狗
這隻狗跟我們在台灣在林口
也不是說他生活不好
其實秋口生活很好
他一兩禮拜去是沙漏
他都會去做頭髮的整理
親耳朵什麼的
我老婆都說狗過的生活比較好
然後他吃很好的飼料
然後接著像我太太是有那種
怎麼講自己的一些那種強迫症
就是一天一定要帶他出去好幾次
然後一定要走到固定的步數也是不錯
只是就是說在一個那種都市叢林的感覺
好像說如果那時候我們沒有遇到他
說不定在更好的地方
對啊但退彎不來講
像是吸爆就是之前那隻貓咪
然後或是球口
遇到我們就是生活會有所提升
總比在外面好
真的是這樣
也能夠就是靠這樣的一些想法
讓自己稍微好過一點
那我覺得其實寵物就跟孩子一樣了
你就會希望他更好
你不會覺得說
當然你跟朋友講話的時候
他過那麼爽
類似我說媽 秋狗過那麼爽
可是你心中就還是會覺得
有沒有可能讓他過得更好之類
因為這些東西太珍貴了
他們是真心的愛你
然後你像我剛剛前面講
人與人之間沒有信任
狗跟你之間 狗不會算計你
狗真的不會
我又扯到狗
為什麼你們每次來跟我講貓咪
我最後沒有講回狗
因為我覺得狗是更加單純的存在
貓咪不一定
貓咪狗都會想要陷害你
對 但也是蠻可愛蠻好玩的
下面一位
嗨嗨謝夢公只能夠偷偷問你了
相比於在全台碰運氣遇到你
我覺得New Balance的10公里馬拉松
終點等你的機會大一點
請求預約和你拍照
會先讓你喘個幾下差低
希望有機會願望一次滿足
有你還有Lisa和兩個兒子
當然是沒有問題
基本上我覺得台灣人都非常的友善
至少在台灣做一個小名人我至今是沒有不舒服的體驗真的沒有影響就是完全沒有所以我覺得大家的分寸都很好像一開始有人會講說會不會有人在那邊跑步跑一跑
然後居然停下來拍照
我覺得就不會遇到這種人
台灣的素質其實真的是蠻高的
所以都不用想太多
我就只是一般人
其實我至今都還是有點搞不懂
你們為什麼要拍照到底怎麼拍的
但你們要幹嘛
我就能夠做的
大家開心都可以啦
小事情
下面一位
當我遠揚夢光安康
育兒的路上有淚
有泪有欢笑
前面是很累
后面是那个眼泪的泪
那幸好有老婆这个神队友
还有梦公跟众多捏软针线的空中陪伴
觉得27号是我的太太
aka弯曲林志玲的生日
她的生日用上是听到你再次
把跳槽捏成跳蛋
然后再加重她四个字
也祝梦公和各位空中的朋友们
喝家健康平安
跳蛋生日快乐
希望这个心想事成
但有些人跟我讲说
其实尽量不要乱住心想事成
因为我们很常会有不好的想法
或想要害别人
或是说生气的时候
一个念头闪过去
但最后面就还好没有做
所以心想的东西也不要全部事成
但是愿望可以获得实现
这样不讲
我觉得愿望比心中想到的东西
更加的实际
我到底在mursage
我不知道在murmur什么
下面有一位
很持久
是韭菜的酒
梦工看问题就知道
干归很多次
那想问之前回答说
资金转去胜盔谷0050个指数
这样不是满手多单吗
什么情况下会上空单避险
季限下完还是很弹性平直觉
风高避险跟叠式开始才避的困惑
那另外提问纳斯达克要连续开盘23小时
其实不太懂小纳跟纳斯达克
成分股没跟着开的话
这样是有什么意义跟影响
那最后会让小孩也学钢琴吗
安哥是不是蛮适合培养成运动员
对球好像很有兴趣
对目前看起来他对运动类型的东西
特别的有想法
而且他的力道也蛮大的
不会说要培养为运动员
但会先往就是我们观察到
他的一些特质去努力
就類似說諾亞他的耳朵是聽得出來
寶可夢那種各種機台奇怪的聲音
一般聽不太懂他聽得出來
所以就想說可能有機會讓他學一下音樂
我們會先要往那個方向去推沒錯
再來講說指數如果開盤23小時的影響是什麼
就像是台紙他也是晚上會開夜盤
有些夜盤的期貨也會動
一些大票像台積電會變得動
可是問題是其他是沒有開的
但你說這樣就不影響嗎還是會
就是它就是有點給你一個early indication的感覺
你今天看到夜盤期貨狂跌
就可以期待
明天東西跟著跌的機率會高一點也不一定有時候像夜盤狂跌跌完早上反而就直接開低一堆人停損之後就殺出去它可以作為一個reference
但是你說對每支絕對標的
可不可以很明確的講出它的影響
那個是沒有辦法的
然後再來講說
之前回檔的時候轉進去這幾個
我認為是比較偏向防守性的東西
這樣還是滿手奪單
對沒錯就是滿手奪單
因為對我來說
我之前有一集有跟大家聊過
它會隨著你目前的year today的一個變化
會有所變化
至少以我自己的策略會這樣
就是因為今年就真的太好了
所以我會覺得我可以跟你評看看
我也可以拗久一點
所以才會導致像前面有一些
本來賺蠻多的東西
然後在7月回檔就跌到相對蠻深的地方
我才把它停立出去
因為我的心態就是反正我已經
那個都是幾百%的東西
我根本就沒差
我現在隨便賣又賺錢
就是沒有人說給你回這麼深
後來還是打到心中設定的一些標準會出去
這個就是因為你前面已經拉出去很遠了
但如果說像今年的報酬就只有個
可能10-20%
再往下就會直接轉負的話
就會立刻轉為比較防守的姿態
所以其實會每年都把它重新計算的感覺
也不會說什麼
因為我的資產相較於前幾年已經多很多
所以我現在可以隨便玩
不會就還是會把錢當前很認真看
那就用可能每年每季這樣去看
所以如果今天已經是狀況是不太好了
接著又再繼續往下破的話
就會進入更加防守的一個姿態
空單可能是比較罕見的狀況才會上
就是已經明確知道初始了
以2022來講
我的空單是等到第一季第二季以後才開始上去的
當然有些人會講說他一早就空
我只能夠說這種
跟你講說什麼摸頭去空的
那就代表說在多頭的路上
他早就已經不知道被嘎多少次了
就是你不可能每次都是剛好摸到最高點
所以我們的做法還是
我要看到一些indication
我才會去做相對應的調整
盡量不會自己去亂猜
特別是
如果說你在過去是做這種
Pair trade的
除非你是一些機構有被要求或什麼的
不然我會覺得蠻可惜的
因為這個算是
我不敢講說是幾十年一遇這種事情
搞不好台灣還是會開大運還是很多年
可是它確實是一個非常罕見的行情
就是狂噴亂噴
在2020以後好像說
就是這些股市的參與者
新大運很多人都發大財
如果說你做太多那種疊床駕駱
自以為的避險
我以前很早期會笑
散戶的避險都越避越險
你最後面就是雙把
其實都會對績效造成一定程度影響
有時候你就是想簡單一點
你就是回歸到投資的本質
玩玩玩 投資是什麼
就是你找好公司 買進並等待
你在過去有吃過這些波段的人
你會對這段話很有感受
你就會知道
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕